okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i have two special guests
on the platform i have ari um
i was gonna say from flutter but it's
not that anymore
and dante they are both dating coaches
on tick tock with
a combined over a half a million
followers
welcome to the just pearly things show
guys thank you thank you for having us
um so today um i've actually introduced
them to some clips from the manosphere
neither of them um are super heavy
watchers but they've both seen a couple
clips so we're just going to talk about
some topics
in the minnowsphere so
my question is what is the context of
the clip that you
uh gave us um it's a show
so basically um fresh and fit they're
like the
i would say one of the most
controversial podcasts in the manosphere
in my opinion
um and they they kind of just say like
very
um like it's like
i would say the fast life is what they
promote for like both men and women
and women go on the show and then
they'll have kevin samuels like call in
and then they just talk
about different topics on the show is
that what you meant
yeah i was kind of confused about like
what because
it just seemed like they were having a
really heated conversation so i thought
i would ask you
and kind of get some context
oh no i got none i'm going to be honest
i just want i just watched the clip i
was like oh that's interesting and i
sent it to you guys
i think in general though i actually
have watched a few other episodes and i
think in general ari that's pretty much
what it is like they have
females come onto the show they'll have
a conversation with them and then they
usually debate
whether it be about you know feminism or
whatever it is
and then kevin samus will call in on
some of the episodes and then he'll talk
to the females about it and then
i hate saying females women sorry
they'll go back and forth
and they'll basically just talk about
each point of view and then it usually
ends up being an argument or someone
leaving a show so
damn um so i was just curious what did
you guys
think when you initially saw the clips
uh obviously that one was very
controversial so
um tell me your biggest disagreement and
we could talk about it
oh okay cool um well i think that
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of steamrolling that happened in that
conversation
and i think both parties have a really
a huge misunderstanding what feminism is
because feminism
is equal about equality on both sides
and i think a lot of social media
and media in general like modern day
media has
painted feminism in a way that
academia i hate saying academia but
determines that straw feminism where
you're kind of using a straw argument
to cherry pick arguments that suit
your own point of view and in reality
like i think he brought up some really
great points about
you know there is a huge double standard
when it comes to dating because
you know men are expected to put their
best foot forward
they're expected to conform to gender
norms and you know women get a lot of
benefits
at the same time like for example when
he brought up the vegas nightclub and
how you get free drinks
yeah yeah and that is a double standard
and i think
that the biggest problem that a lot that
they didn't address was
a lot of gender norms that are put into
place are a byproduct of
you know i hate saying this the
patriarchy and the patriarchy not only
you know
it hurts not only women but it hurts men
because it reinforces
these toxic ideals that you know men
have to be the breadwinners
that they have to be stoic or that they
have to
you know buy a woman a drink right when
in reality i think
we should just be looking at people as
people not based on their
you know what they identify as and i
think it's just about respect
and if you look at arguments at the end
of the day you know both
both parties are saying i i have a
problem with this
i have a problem with this i have a
problem with this right but all they
wanted was respect
and i think that's a conversation that
they should have had
rather than trying to pick apart each
other's arguments and steamroll each
other so
that was kind of my biggest takeaway
from it but overall it was
you know as a female it was really hard
to hear some of the arguments that kevin
stanles had to say
but what what like arguments were hard
to hear for you
i wrote a few down um so
let's see so one of the arguments he
talked about was that women aren't
bringing enough to the table
and that a lot of younger females who
are in college
or you know our age are expecting a man
to make
over six figures and like okay and that
women are bringing enough to the table
and i think
that was really it was hard to hear
because
personally and my my own experience
isn't a reflection of
the rest of the world because i've had
my parents to support me
financially they put me through school i
was on a scholarship
not because of a needs-based thing but
because of my grades and
you know i've had the best tutors i've
been given pretty much everything
right and so i've worked really hard to
get to where i
am and that's just a socio-economic
factor
that creates huge huge discrepancies in
society and yes things are unfair but
it's also
it's also about you know socioeconomic
status and how that really gives
other people opportunities right and i
think also it was just hard to hear
because
there are so many women oh sorry so
question do you would you only date a
guy that makes six figures
no largely because i personally
don't rely on them to pay the bill okay
and i know we've had this conversation
like that
yeah i don't expect a man to pay for on
the first day
okay yeah because i would like my
partner to make equal income
and i've i've had my own ambitions and
so
i don't want to go throughout life
expecting to rely on someone else
for their own finances or and
i also think that you know when you're
dating someone you're
oh sorry so if you were to be married
you'd be like cool with the 50 50
for like the whole relationship yeah
okay yeah yeah that makes sense then
what did you think dante um
kind of like ari said i think it was
very controversial and i think each side
had good points and one of the points
that i think the females on the show had
was that they just don't feel understood
and they don't feel heard and i think
you need to be empathetic towards that
because a man we don't fully understand
what you guys go through
and i don't think that kevin samus does
a very good job of
you know embracing that and being
pathetic towards what women are saying
i think he's very harsh i think he's
very blunt which is good but at the same
time
if you're going to be a consultant
you're going to coach people you have to
lead with empathy and say you know i
might not agree with what you're saying
but understand where you're coming from
this is what i would do but instead of
that just you know can i cuss on here
yeah i don't care okay instead of that
it's just like you know [ __ ] you you're
being a [ __ ] or whatever it is like
it's very
it's very to the point but at the same
time it's also very demeaning and to
women
and to men too that's not productive it
doesn't help and i think you have to
have it you have to have a balance
like you have to be honest with yourself
but you also can't just completely bash
yourself
um so i'm just curious as a guy um
did you find that the stuff they were
saying was true or false like when they
say that like
men don't care about a woman's career
and they don't care about her money as a
guy
if you were dating a girl that made like
significantly less than you would you
care
for me it's more so about ambition and
if you have something that you want to
work towards so i don't really care
what you make because for me personally
i make my own money and i'm going to
make a lot of money
i just know that for myself yeah so i
want my wife to be happy
you know if she wants to provide i'm not
going to say no you can't make a certain
amount of money you can't go make more
money than me if you want to go do it
but i just care that you have your own
passions your own desires and that you
can do something day-to-day that you're
fulfilling
okay that's fair enough um and
a couple other things sorry to cut you
off but a couple other things i noticed
that i agreed with on kevin samuel side
of things i didn't think he was wrong in
every aspect necessarily at least my
point of view
was selective feminism is a big problem
yeah so
and yeah and he uses a lot of examples
which i thought were very true
and i think when we talk about equality
there's a quality of opportunity and a
quality of outcome which he speaks about
and i think we have to take that into
account there's you know
there's a huge distinction between the
two so uh that i agreed with
the things that i didn't agree with i'll
get more into depth like as the podcast
goes along
but one of the biggest ones this was
actually on a separate podcast but he
states that women need men
no matter how much money you make no
matter how much you can provide for
yourself
a woman needs a man or she'll die
unhappy
i don't personally agree with that i
think there are plenty of women that
have made it on their own that have been
happy they don't need a man and his
point was you can't be
um i'm trying to remember how he worded
it but is essentially you can't be good
enough
if you don't have a man and i think
that's just i think that's ridiculous
personally
um see i actually do think women need
men
no i think they do but i think to say
you need a man to be successful is
ridiculous that's the distinction i'm
not saying you don't need
to be happier you can't provide uh a
loving life with one another or you
can't have children like
i'm just saying you don't need a man to
be happy i don't
um see actually what i meant what i
understood his argument
was that um men run a lot of like
the industries that keep society going
so like if you call a handyman it's
usually a guy
if you call a mechanic it's usually a
guy so when he said like do we need men
what i actually thought of was like most
women like don't do those things
does that make sense there's some it's
just i'd say like it's more the
exception rather than the rule
can i can i say something yeah so i
actually have a problem with
that argument because you know when it
comes to equal opportunities in
education
you have to remember women didn't have
the right to go to school until
like the mid-1900s right and
two and also like now we have one what
is
what does that have anything to do with
me now so you know like
so but the the reason why a lot of women
aren't
professions is because they weren't
given the opportunity
due to legal ramifications and
institutions right
they couldn't you know go into trade
schools or they couldn't go into law
school and
um title nine was just recent was passed
not that long ago as well
and you know that's ensuring equal
opportunity across the board so
i think that's why we don't normally see
people fix like you know toilets and
have trade jobs and all that
so are just women now i see it see i
would disagree with you because
me what a policy from the 1900s that
doesn't affect
me today i just genuinely would never
want to be a plumber a mechanic or any
of those things
i have every opportunity to go do that
if i want to
i just literally would never want to do
that in my life well
i think the thing is is that you might
not want to
but think about it this way we put in
okay so when it comes to civil rights
with the black community right
they have been you know oppressed for
the longest time and brown v board of
education was passed to integrate
schools racially
and we've had to implement diversity
quotas in order to make sure
that because these people have been held
back for such a long time
and it takes time for progress to ramp
up
that had to put in like things like
diversity quotas and
you know how would you know the
difference between people just like
choosing what they want to choose versus
like not being able to do that
so like especially like like i think
like a quota
you're gonna say like you have to have
this amount of people but i'll give you
an example i was in the copier sales
industry before
and they could never meet their quota
because women didn't want to sell
copiers
it was a terror it's a terrible job it's
the worst job i've ever had in my life
and so it wasn't necessarily that they
didn't have the opportunity
but they would hire pretty much any
woman that walked through the door
because they're so desperate for female
sales people at a big corporate company
do you know what i'm saying so do you
think it's more so the marketing that
goes into these things
no really a terrible job i think like
men are just more willing to do terrible
jobs in my opinion i would have to agree
with you and i think there's a lot of
women that have
they could go do those things i heard
someone argue with me yesterday that
there's not enough female mechanics
why would you want to be a mechanic it's
terrible work no
yeah like it's not that you can't do it
i've seen female mechanics but
the vast majority of them are going to
be men that are providing for their
family because they're willing to do
that work
yeah so my argument would be too you
know why would women want to do that
work
i so i can't definitively give you guys
an answer right
but like i think also it comes down to
individual preferences right like maybe
someone who
likes cars is going to go into like
doing a dirty job right
and like pearl and i aren't going to
choose it because we don't
want to do it i don't want to do it i'm
i'm a little princess i'm like
i don't want to touch this like ew right
but you know i'll gladly like plumb my
toilet if i have to
or but i think it's just individual
preference
yeah i guess but what i'm saying is
right now there's no laws in place that
would prevent women from doing that
like even the women the women that were
born today never had a law
in place to stop them i was told from a
very young age
you're a girl you can do whatever you
want and me
every girl i know not one of them went
into the trades because the trades suck
and i don't think that's society i just
think like because if it was society
there would be a lot in place to stop
them
if anything girls look like i think they
look cool
but they have like you know like their
mechanic a plum plumber whatever
i just don't think girls want to do it
do you think it has to come down to
more so a financial standpoint because i
could
i could get a here's the thing is like
for let's talk about tech for
for a second like tech jobs are grossly
overpaid
like you can make as an entry-level
director in marketing
you can make 120 to 130 000 dollars
i'm not gonna just choose yeah and
that's
easy that's base and then you also have
comp and like
a lot of people are going more towards
tech jobs and so
do you think it has to do more so with
the money versus like
women make ten thousand dollars less
than men like on
average and it's not the pay gap it's
the industries they choose
so like like trades make a ton of money
especially nowadays
like i worked at a plumbing place i
didn't do it i was like the marketing
person
but i'm telling you those those plumbers
had great hours and they brought in cash
like they were making like like i'm
pretty sure if you get a plumbing
apprenticeship
they pay for your school so you don't go
into debt and you start off at like 60k
a year
which is nuts for like an entry like an
18 year old
so pearl's point too i heard jordan
peterson talk about this and he was
talking about women choosing their
industry
and i think it's an interesting
statistic because you talk about the pay
gap and a large
portion of that is because women are
choosing lower tier jobs so it's not
necessarily that you can't go get the
job it's that you're choosing not to
and to no fault the jobs that a lot of
men choose if you want to climb to the
ladder and get to the top and be a ceo
it's really [ __ ] hard it's not easy
there's a ton of pressure you're not
going to be with your family
so why would you want to go do that it's
not that you can't it's that most women
choose not to
and an example for a woman that does
that is sarah blakely she started spanx
with five thousand dollars
now she's worth a billion it's not to
say that you can't do those things a lot
of women choose not to
yeah and to piggyback off of that like
my dad is like very successful he's the
top probably like half a percent
in terms of earners of that like he did
very well we have
like 10 or nine siblings lived in a big
house whatever
but success comes at a cost and that
cost was i barely saw him growing up
you know so um and the thing is
did you hear when jordan peterson was
talking about how law firms couldn't pay
lawyers to stay
because they because at around 30 to 35
these women wanted to go with kids
yeah yeah it's a huge argument
all right i'd like to hear your you know
your point of view on that because i
think
a lot of women project the idea that i
can't get this job or i can't go into
this field i can't go into this industry
when really it's all in your head
the opportunity's there and there might
be certain areas i'm not saying in every
area
but there are a lot of areas that women
think they have this projection that
they can't get into it when really they
can just no one's done it yet
and if we're ever evolving and we're
creating these equality of outcomes
um or quality of opportunity rather
excuse me then
you know someone needs to take a stand
and do it
yeah i i will say that when we talk
about the gender pay gap
it has to go more towards more social
science fields
um and like teaching for example um
but you know in in more heavily demanded
jobs like tech
or engineering right like women aren't
paid
are aren't like it's pretty equal like
we're matched with like males
right but i think there there is some
truth and validity to the point of like
yeah women aren't choosing these jobs
and
with the law firm thing i mean the law
profession itself is such a traditional
profession that has
it's really it's brutal because you're
working
over 80 to 100 hour weeks you know
parents want to be with their children
and then
america has maternity laws where you
know
our maternity leave is structured for
like maybe i think it's like
what like 40 weeks or i don't know what
the the thing is but like in other
european countries that
might have more monoethnic like cultures
where everyone like for example
amsterdam
where everyone like agrees to do
something for
the benefit of community like they have
more they have better maternity loss for
that like because people are gonna
abide by a lot of their countries like
um
what's called norms in in standards but
i think it is a deeper conversation that
needs to be had about
how america runs you know treats
its workers right um that's not to say
that you know there's a discrepancy of
women in in trade jobs right because
they are hard
and law is a really really grueling
profession i think
that maybe they need maybe it's not so
much about increasing
pay because i know tons of people who
are making
250 000 a year and have decided to leave
their job in tech because it's so
much work and they're like i'm burned
out my job is my entire identity
i don't feel like i've used my 20s to
you know
explore the world and we're over here
making content
and doing what we love right because
we've been told to pursue what we're
passionate about
but all these people who have took this
traditional route of going to law school
of you know going into finance and
working these stressful like
long hours they they end up leaving
because no amount of money will make
them stay
at one point you know the margin
the what is it the opportunity cost for
like the
next additional margin isn't worth the
increase in salary
yeah but that's a choice though that's
the only thing i would say about that
is they chose to go into that field and
i feel a lot of empathy if someone's
that stressed out
because you don't want to do something
invisible and the first thing i would
ever promote to someone if they want to
get into a field is do something that
you love
and if you have to do something that you
hate for a little while that gets where
you love them do that
but to say that we need to feel bad for
these people because they chose the
wrong industry that was a choice you
didn't have to go to school for eight
years and get in that field
you could do whatever you want to so
does that
well that's actually really true but
does that discredit the fact that we
need to have another conversation about
you know what needs to change so that we
make the industry no question
no question i think we need to change
the way that our schooling system is run
100 and i think danta you have a really
good
um understanding a great story actually
about how you're like i want to do what
i
love and i'm doing my own thing and i
know our first conversation on the phone
was
you talking about i want to create my
own business i love business
and that's what i'm going to do and it's
going to be hard and and i have a lot of
respect for that right and so
i think i think there's two there's
there's so this is
a kind of a complex issue because not
only is it surrounding like
you know american institutions is
everything okay
girl
oh um i'm back hello
um i i think there's like a it's a it's
there's so many different facets to the
problem that we can't definitely point
to
one thing so it might be people make the
choice not to work these jobs two it
could be
you know social economic status it could
be you know institutions it
it and so yeah it's a it is at the
when i talk about these issues i start
to realize that everything is really
complex
i think it's complex but i think there's
a very simplistic answer to these
questions
and that is that kids are being
influenced by their parents who are only
known they only know one way right let's
go to school get an education
pay off your debt for the next 20 years
let the interest build on that debt
that's your parents projecting on to you
what they think you should do and as a
kid
think of when you're five years old
right you think you can do anything or
when you're a baby and you're learning
how to walk and crawl
you're gonna get up and do it again and
do it again and do it again as soon as
someone tells you you can't do that
anymore that's when we start to hit our
mindset and our growth
so i think the answer is society is
ruining all these kids mindsets
our school system traditional school
system is completely tampering people's
abilities and what they actually can do
and it's telling you if you don't go to
school you're not enough
if you don't go get an education not
going to be anything in this world and
that's simply not
true and i'm a leading example i went to
school for college basketball i know you
did two pearl
and that's the only reason that i went
but i never liked school i never agreed
with the school system i always said why
are we learning this and i never got an
answer and i was actually pulled aside
and told to stop asking questions that
is not an environment that i want to be
in
that is not a world that we should live
in like i said we're ever evolving and
things are changing
the fact that you can go and pay for a
200 program and make 200 000
a year six months later is mind-blowing
that's the world that we live in it's
not go to school get education anymore
school education has actually dropped
the rate of kids that go to school for
the first time in 90 years it dropped a
year ago
it started going backwards well the the
problem with education is that um
when they subsidized education in the
1960s
what happened was they caught they were
able to increase the cost of education
without the value of education going up
so you see like
colleges with rock climbing walls and
like like extravagant things that don't
actually make you better like better at
learning
does that make sense so um so basically
the government said i'll give you bigger
and bigger loans
and so the colleges were like okay let's
make it more and more expensive
because everyone gets a loan no matter
what and therefore the
then they had no um repercussions
because the quality of education didn't
have to increase because everyone got a
loan
even if they couldn't afford it yeah and
you look at it from
you can use the same example with
housing right look at the 2008 crash the
reason that happened is because everyone
was able to get a loan
and when you do that and people aren't
responsible and the same goes for credit
cards
people don't know how to live in the
real world so you go to school you're
not taught how to pay your bills you're
not taught how to sign a lease you're
not taught how to
do all these things so when you have to
do it you don't understand it that's
when people get in these terrible
situations
so in the school systems we need to be
teaching people how to think and not
what to think
and that's not to say that school is a
bad thing i think school has a lot of
good inherent qualities and i think it
teaches a lot of good lessons
but i do not think that we should tell
every single kid you have to go to
school
i i 100 agree um because i come from a
family
on my mom's side everyone has their
college degree and
i think it's like 10 out of
no 15 out of 30. it's like half of my
family out of 30 family members
has their phd and i
hated my undergrad in fact i took a long
time to finish
and i finished when i was 25 and
it's because i just was like i don't
want to do this but my family was like
you have to like
finish it and it was i had everyone
on my side like funding me and like
telling me you know you have to go
you should utilize this opportunity
which i'm going to because i'm eternally
grateful
but had i not had that influence
i would have 100 not gone with college i
don't even use my college degree
i am you know i'm doing really great
things
in my career yeah totally and i don't
think that
having a college degree really brought
any value in fact it's incredibly
embarrassing
to me when i talk about this because i'm
like i
initially spent so much money getting
this degree and the school gave me
like a full-ride scholarship so i didn't
pay my last year of
my senior year but the fact that i put
so much money into this stupid piece of
paper
is kind of it's embarrassing because i
it's like what am i gonna do with this
right and i think it's also just a
byproduct of
almost classism where people are like if
you're wealthy you go to college and you
get opportunities but in reality that's
not how the world works anymore
no it's not um okay dante i had a
question for you
um so specifically from a guy's
perspective who do you think has more
privileges
men are women typically i think it
depends on the area that you're talking
about
so i think if you're talking about you
know an industry or an area where women
are more
densely populated they're probably going
to have more opportunity but i think
overall uh you know it's a tough
question
i can't fully answer that i don't know
to be honest with you i think it really
depends on the industry i think it
depends on the area you're talking about
but overall i'd say men feel like
they have the confidence to do more
because that's been the norm for so many
years right
i you know i'm not going to sit here and
deny that women have been oppressed for
thousands of years because they have
and i truly believe that and i was
raised around very strong women that
would you know articulate that
so i think we're getting to a point
where
opportunity is abundant so anyone can
take an opportunity so
i couldn't sit here and say it's 60 40
like i really don't know a number
but i would say it's getting close to a
point where women can do everything that
a man does
and free of judgment i would hope you
know
yeah um the reason so the reason i asked
you that
was um until i started watching like
content from men's point of view
i didn't really understand actually all
the privileges you do get as a girl
um not necessarily
for like great reasons but because men
like
more men are in um power positions
so a lot of those men are like attracted
to you so um
i think she's going out again there you
go you're back no
no sorry my modified yeah i have to have
too many siblings on it
um where did i cut off uh you're just
talking about that women have
you feel women have more rights or you
didn't realize how many rights women are
afforded
or opportunity rather yeah i'll give you
an example okay so
um there's a big wrapper that i wanted
on my channel right and i wanted to do a
collab
um so one yay obviously has millions of
followers
i have fifteen thousand subscribers on
youtube
guess which one did he respond to the
rapper we both dm'd him who did he
respond to
um i would like to say one year just
because he has a following but maybe you
yeah like me even though i have way less
but it's because like
he you know he's probably trying to do i
don't know but
i'm not saying it's for good reasons but
i would in that case get that
opportunity that he didn't
do you know what i'm saying just because
from that perspective
from that perspective i agree with you
but i think that's the men's fault
almost because i think men can't control
a lot of their urges yeah
so i think yeah if you're gonna put it
like that i would agree with you
you want to call it that or even um
a lot of times you'll see girls that
talk about um
just um how they regret doing like
different
um i don't know like sex work you'd say
like strip or whatever
and later they'll say oh no like i
regret this whatever but the guys will
be like
well you're [ __ ] out of luck like i i
was broke and i didn't take that you
know
like i didn't even i couldn't even take
that route oh yeah
let me i'll give you an example too
because i actually have a lot of women
that have reached out to me about
scenarios similar to this and one of
them was
how do you feel about a woman she
actually reached me and she did this
she went to school in new york she
didn't have any family she didn't have
the money
so you know she found a sugar daddy and
he paid her to come over on the weekends
they'd have sex and then he'd pay for
her school and a place to live
is that right i don't personally agree
with it but i think if you need to do
what you need to do as i said earlier to
get into a better situation i'm not
going to stay here and judge you
i prefer you didn't because i think
you're going to lose a lot of your value
in doing something like that
yeah would you date a girl that did that
no
yeah and that's that's what i think
girls don't realize the consequences to
that stuff until
the guys don't want to date them because
they did that stuff
i i i do want to chime in here and say
that
you know i i do agree with dante that
you have to do what it's going to take
to pay
off the bills right and sometimes that
means sacrificing your own well-being
but oftentimes when we talk about sex
work and only fans
what a lot of people don't talk about
is how sex work is actually really
closely real like tied to human
trafficking and
how we all have this idea of okay
it's icky it doesn't like i don't want
to date someone that's you know that has
engaged in sex work great
but also you don't want your partner
engaging in
activities that are gonna potentially
put them into danger like that and
putting your body
on the internet i get that porn like you
know porn is you know
i don't think we should be body shaming
i don't think we should be you know
basically saying oh you can't like be a
porn star you can't go into only things
right
but rather i think that it's just a huge
safety aspect as well
when it comes to putting your own
identity online and exposing yourself
like that
and um i think that's all often the
reason why a lot of people are like i
don't want to be
around that too because it's it's really
dangerous if you think about it and
i mean we live in america and we we
probably are live in areas where human
trafficking
isn't rampant but if you go somewhere
like honduras right
honduras has tons of human trafficking
and a lot of women probably have to
some women have to resort to sex work to
like make the bills and then they get
involved in gang related activity as
well so
yeah and that's my point i don't agree
with it i would never do it personally
um
i've actually been told they can only
fans thousands of times and i'd be
making a lot of money if i did
but i i i will not do that you know my
morals personally my moral compass
doesn't allow me to do things like that
and i'm grateful for that but i'm again
i'm not going to put anybody down but i
think there's a huge distinction and
this is a good topic because there's two
women on here
is there's a huge difference between
owning your body embracing your body and
then selling your body for clout or
money or fame
and i think when you do that you attach
your identity to your body and from that
you can never be happy in anything else
because if you're out of shape or if you
don't look a certain way if your makeup
is not done you never feel like you're
enough and that's not good that's not
healthy
yeah yeah that's a really good point
dante
i 100 agree and i think a lot of the
time as women
we're expected to feel like we have to
look a certain way
and especially like straight women you
know
we have to conform to certain beauty
standards
and that's so damaging as a young
wait hold on sorry sorry to cut you off
yeah do you feel that because it's a
good topic do you feel like you
have to conform to them or do you feel
like society's put the pressure on you
to conform to them like do you
personally feel like i have to look a
certain way
that's actually a really good question
because it's there's a big distinction
you know you brought that up and
i think when i was younger i definitely
felt like there was a huge pressure to
conform because i was bullied
i like was bullied for my looks and i
had really bad acne when i was younger
and um
and that was really damaging and it was
actually a lot of
guys in my grade that picked on me and
made me feel like i was
inferior and made me feel like i was
ugly right and
you know a lot of the time women are
supposed to
follow this or feel pressured to follow
the standard right
and it's you're absolutely right when it
comes to attaching your own identity to
your body
because for the longest time i was like
i don't look this certain
a certain way i don't i'm fat or you
know i'm not like i don't look like
x y and z but in reality i wasn't
looking
at wow i'm really smart i'm really
driven i'm ambitious i'm like
i think i'm funny i have i love it i
have
parents who love me and so it is very
very damaging because you don't think
about
the other things that are actually
really important and it does weigh on
your mental health as well
what about you i think oh sorry let's go
ahead bro i'll
give my feedback after that um i
actually
what was the cool i forgot what the
beginning question was do you feel like
you feel pressured to look a certain way
because it's
you you telling yourself you have to or
do you feel like it's pressure from
outside sources whether that be parents
society boyfriend whatever
um i would say
the only time i felt like a pressure to
look a certain way was when
guys would like always ask me about my
friends
and not me you know what i mean you kind
of feel some type of way when they're
like
who's your friend but um
but i actually realized um through the
manosphere like a societal
um so
i'm sorry i'm not articulating this well
what prayer okay what percent of single
men
do you think are sexually active this
seems like a random question but i'm
going to get to
like what i'm asking 25 percent uh
defined sexually active like just
actually having sex or like making out
or like
i'm gonna be honest i'm not a hundred
percent sure but i would say actually
having sex probably in the last like
three months
[Music]
wow you guessed it right ari really yeah
so twenty
twenty percent of men have sexual access
to eighty percent of women
so what i think it is is a lot all the
girls want the same guys and so those
guys
when they don't give those girls the
attention they want that their
self-esteem goes down and they don't
even see eighty percent of men
that's my analysis interesting i've
actually never heard that statistic
before
yeah and so like uh what i've found is
like the angriest girls
um that i see on social media all the
time are always like cute
and it's because the guys that's like so
like a quote-unquote nine or ten
hooks up with the girl but won't date
her because she's cute
but not on like his the level he wants
yeah
um that's a good point uh because i have
a lot of content for once you don't
watch my content it's
mainly surrounding mental health fitness
but also a lot about relationships and
how i feel that women have been
undervalued over the past years
and more so the way that women women
treat men and men treat women
too especially yeah the distinction
between men and
boys the distinction between women and
girls and i think
to your point because i've never heard
that statistic before but this goes hand
in hand with what
a lot of what i talk about is women are
chasing after these guys
trying to find a high-value man and
really what ends up happening is to get
these guys that they think are
high-value men and then they end up
hurting them yeah
and to my point and to your point it's
because those men don't want that
and because of that they go and find
whatever they can rather than unquote
the cream of the crop
and they get hurt and they get damaged
and they think every man is like that
and that's just simply not true
but the men that the men that aren't
like that aren't going to put up with
your [ __ ] if you're someone that's
immature
if you're someone who's not a
communicate if you're someone that
doesn't want something for yourself
so what i would say is if you feel it's
only happening to you
and you feel like you're enough take a
look in the mirror and ask yourself am i
really doing anything that i can
to be the best partner am i really doing
everything i can to value myself
do i feel that i'm enough for me and if
you don't feel that don't get into a
relationship because you're not going to
be able to embrace love when it comes to
you
from someone that truly loves you who
you are and i think a lot of women have
a lot of trauma that they haven't dealt
with
from those like from those like i think
a lot of girls
get um used by those guys in like
situation shifts or whatever feel
terrible because i don't think women
naturally can do that like i think it's
harder for women than men to have casual
relationships
um i don't know about that you don't you
don't think so
i think it i think it leans in favor of
men but i can tell you personally
because i'm objectified by a lot of
women on a daily basis
that they really don't know yeah there
are enough women
out there that do the same thing that
men do but it's just not highlighted
they don't talk about it women
you know women women will talk about it
when they're in the same presence but
it's never objectified to the rest of
the men in the world right
that's never like some men don't realize
that women are having those
conversations like oh like women
objectify men all the time i get cackled
every time i go running and i just don't
talk about it because i don't care
but to say that it doesn't happen or
women don't just want to have hookups
and like
it it happens i think it it does lean in
favor of men though
yeah i just i think that like women will
take a casual hookup even though they
don't want it a lot of the time
i would agree with that too you know
what they they want more but they just
accept that
and i think like that is more
emotionally damaging
to women just my perspective i could be
wrong than men like i think
men are more able to just have sex with
a girl and not have feelings
do you think that's wrong dante yeah for
me personally i don't agree with that
i think again i do not consider myself
to think like most men do i'm not saying
i'm better than anybody
yeah i just think the way that i was
raised around a lot of women it's made
me a lot more emotional than most guys
and i may not always um i may not
necessarily articulate it or let the
girl know
but i'm a very deep thinker and so for
me like for example
if i'm having sex with someone i'd much
rather have it be an emotional
connection if we're just having sex
to me i i feel terrible i feel like i
just use the girl if i'm just like all
right we have sex and then like go home
yeah
like i can't i'm not someone that does
that so i ca i don't think you can say
every guy's like that but i think there
are a lot of guys that pretend to be
like
that but they really do feel it they get
extremely damaged they never express it
and then they go and hurt a bunch of
other people so it's not that they don't
feel it it's that they don't articulate
it so do you think it's even then would
you say in your experience
i think it's like i said i think it's
articulated differently but i think it's
close to being
i think it's close to being even yeah
okay i think
one of the biggest issues when it comes
to casual sex between
men and women is that men from an early
age are told
to repress their emotions and that they
can't you know explain like
emote have an emotional outlet and
that's actually really dangerous because
it doesn't teach them how to you know
identify their emotions and what they're
feeling and come to terms with it
and i think women are put into this
position where they're hurt
and they're expected to just move on
right and in like
the the cultural zeitgeist right now
zeitgeist is
okay i'm i'm a bad [ __ ] i'm gonna go
out i'm gonna hoe around all this stuff
and i'm not gonna sit down and i'm not
gonna go to a therapist and think about
it
and i think that's the biggest problem
and you know dante there's a lot of
power
in admitting that you know i you don't
want to
have a hookup and that you want to just
basically you know
be in tune with your emotions and i i do
want to kind of go back to what we were
talking about in terms of you
getting um cat called and objectified
but because a woman
you know there's this huge conversation
about you know
women being uncomfortable in in speaking
up a lot about
sexual assault or just unwanted advances
right
how do you come to terms with that
because you know you're getting
objectified on a daily basis and no one
should have to go through that right and
so i kind of want to hear what you
have to i don't give a [ __ ] personally i
don't like the world
i don't feel like the world owes me
anything so i'm not gonna sit here and
complain about it
but i do understand that's just how i
feel you know and i'm
i'm strong mentally like i can admit
that for people that aren't
and people that don't value themselves
and people that maybe have a terrible
view of their own self
i feel terrible you know if you go out
and you get catcalled and you're
objectified constantly and you're only
known for your body
that's awful so i have a lot of empathy
for it but for me personally i don't
care
i do however think that there needs to
be a bigger conversation around the fact
that it does happen to men too
and to your point men can't articulate
how they feel without
your you know fear of judgment they feel
like they're not going to be viewed as
manly
or you know they're not strong at that
point they can't be a leader which is
[ __ ]
yeah so not not saying all right that i
don't care but i'm saying for me
personally it doesn't affect me on that
level but i do understand why it would
for a lot of people
yeah i don't care if people can't call
me but i think i'm in the minority of
women
like i just keep walking you know
do you care ari does it bother you a lot
yeah
um only because when i'm alone and i
don't want to be bothered
it tends to happen and like i will
for example i was going to get gas like
on 4th of july
and i was i was i wasn't wearing any
makeup i was wearing my pajamas and some
guy came up to me
and basically was like hey can i get
your number and i said no
um i'm seeing someone and they're like
oh can we like what about just as
friends like can we you know be friends
i was like
i don't think i'd be comfortable with
that and just kept asking
and that is that's what when it bothers
me
and yeah i know how to hold my own but
i can imagine that other women feel
scared and they feel terrified to go
outside and
it's it's hard but at the same time like
i do get bothered by those unwanted like
you know like someone coming up and
talking to me and you know maybe they
have an ulterior motive so that's why
i tend to get bothered and i just want
to touch on that to your point you know
i'm six six 215 pounds so that might be
part of the reason that i don't care if
people objectify me because i know i can
defend myself
if i was five five 120 pounds and i feel
like i couldn't do anything
i'd feel a lot differently me too
actually i'm pretty tall
which is why i say like i i have empathy
towards that situation because i don't
want any woman or man to feel like that
yeah um we're gonna talk about
uh men are trash sorry do you think
that's an okay
all right do you think that's an okay
statement no
um and i i will admit that i'm guilty
of saying that and i actually had a
phone reminder on my
you know phone screen of like men are
trash and it was because i was hurt
by someone that was dated and i was just
really fed up with how i was being
treated
but that's not to say i think it's also
just really
it is toxic because yes there is an
entire conversation that exists
where women are trying to
navigate the way for women's rights and
oftentimes this idea of men or trash is
put into context where
you know women can't control like
how men act towards them but men can
control it right
but i also think this idea that men are
trash is
is incredibly damaging because it's
saying that
implicit in that is okay they are
horrible people
and that they don't deserve rights and
that you know we should treat them
worse than they deserve to be treated
right and and i think
when at the beginning of this
conversation that we had i said people
just need to be respected
and that's that's what it is and i also
think that
it can be very damaging to young men
when they're trying to
navigate their own manhood right
especially straight men
um because if you are mom and you're
saying oh yeah men are trash
what do you think your son is going to
think and i think you
you need to be a good role model and say
hey like this is what's happening
to women all around the world because
men
are objectifying them and there's
there's you know
that women get raped and like all the
stuff that happens but
don't let that discredit the fact that
there are
a lot more underlying issues such as
men's mental health
men's suicide rates you know how there's
injustices when it comes to
custody cases in the legal system when
it comes to you know
kids right so there's a there there's a
lot that we're not talking about when it
comes to
men's social and civil rights
i guess you could put it in that context
but i do think the idea of men are trash
is pretty damaging
i'm glad you said that i actually agree
i think that when women say men are
trash
um you kind of have to look in the
mirror at some point because
nobody is putting a gun to your head and
making you date any of them
so if you think men are trash like maybe
you should think about
the men you're interacting with and the
men you're dating because you pick all
of that
i i do have to say that like sometimes
like dating
dating can be really negative like those
experiences and it
can be it can come from a culture where
you know
men might act a certain way right and so
we have to like have conversations
conversations about dating norms and
safety but
that's not to excuse that people do make
some wrong choices and i don't think we
should also just
i don't think we should just blame the
woman for choosing these men right like
it's it goes both ways and i don't think
women should have to be like oh well
i'm just going to swear off dating all
together um because they should
no i mean i definitely agree like i
think there's some fault on both sides
but
all i'm saying is if you find yourself
and you know fool me once shame on
shame on what is it what's this saying
fool me once shame on you pull me twice
yeah fool me twice shame on me so if
you're finding yourself in the same
situation over and over and over again
you kind of have to ask yourself who's
the common denominator
you know um and i've been there like
i've been burned by a guy before but
i i had to look back and take
responsibility and say
i missed that warning sign that
morningside that warning side like i'm
i'm not gonna be mad at men my brothers
are great guys
like amazing guys so if if um
if i'm gonna blame men like that's not
really fair to the great and
like the great men that are out there
you know i
i think also but the the thing is that
encompassing this idea of men are trash
is that it's like
yes not all men are you know gonna act
horribly towards women i think it's more
so a conversation
about their behaviors and how
they treat women and how they objectify
and there's a lot of sexual assault that
happens and
you know i i think it is like
it is toxic in its own way and i think
the conversation has
fear towards a really horrible direction
where
we're we're taking extreme sides where
it's like okay
screw all men or you know don't join us
and then it's also a matter of okay
woman like women are just being really
toxic towards men
and i think that's that's really
dangerous
um and but that's the problem with
social media is that so much
you know information circulates so many
dialogues circulate that
you know it becomes an echo chamber and
then this new status quo
that could be potentially toxic gets
pushed forward right
um but and i think a lot of women do
understand that
not all men are bad but that doesn't
discount the fact that
men can control their behavior but women
cannot control
who they are as like people right so
wait
i'm sorry i missed a lot of that i was
gone i cut out
basically what i was trying to say was
that men
can control their behaviors and women
cannot
control who they are as people and
they can't control how they look so they
don't deserve to be sexually
objectified but encompassing in this
idea of men are trash is
is is toxic because it's saying all men
but in reality it's
it's not supposed to be that way and
that's what originally the
intent was to say okay not all men are
trash but
they are the reason why this is
happening and that's the conversation
that we should be having but instead
it's
it's took a really bad turn where it's
extreme but the reason the reason that
what's happening
that we're saying [ __ ] all men or men
are trash right no i'm saying like
like you said they're the reason that
this is happening so i was just like
what behavior are you referring to
so like sexually objectifying woman
sexual aggression and this is not to say
that women don't do this to men
do you think okay if a girl do you
i think women objectify themselves a lot
of the time
like they're gonna like my little sister
and all her friends they post their butt
like in their thong swimsuits on social
media
and so like so if guy if guys are
commenting
you know about about stuff like i don't
know the way i see
a lot of the time women like are
throwing their bodies in front of men
and then
like get mad when men comment on it
right so
so that's the thing is that what what
people are trying to say is like
we should be allowed to walk in and just
act freely without having to fear that
men are going to objectify them because
men can control their behavior they can
choose not to make those comments they
can choose not to
you know act really aggressively towards
women
and make them feel unsafe but i just in
my experience
it really hasn't been men like object
like making aggressive comments or this
just me personally usually it's like
the girl's wearing a revealing outfit
and the guy compliments her
and they take that as being objectified
which i i don't i don't really know if
that's
like a bad thing so i was a lot of times
i think they take like
compliments as being objectified so
often times it can come off as unwanted
and people
women don't sometimes they will wear
things for themselves
and they'll do things for themselves and
like that's on them
and i think they just don't
want to be they don't want unwanted
advances
and they don't want to be creeped out
because if you think about it this way
men are allowed to walk around with
their shirts
but how's the guy supposed to know if
it's wanted or unwanted
like like so it's hard for a guy to
approach girls sometimes maybe
he just says like you're pretty you're
beautiful but like is he are you being
objectified then
so it are you even
i think that when it comes to
objectifying women it's like you're only
looking at her for her body
and that's the issue is that we're
commenting on a woman's body when we're
not commenting on her as a whole person
and i think that so would you
would you be offended if a guy that was
like you were talking to
gave you the compliment of like you are
in shape like you very nice body
would that be offensive to you no
because i okay
i want that right and i think it's the
idea of consent versus
non-consent right or non-consensual acts
of like advances right
and oftentimes like what happens is
like men just like people shouldn't even
be making creepy comments in the first
place
and that's okay that's the thing is that
men do because they feel as if they can
and that's what we're saying like
control yourself don't make those creepy
advances but
because i'm seeing this person i've and
i've had a sexual relationship with them
or had sex with them or
you know have an intimate relationship
i'm okay with it and i know the person
but
if it's an actual stranger i'm like
that's gross
right okay so you're talking about
strangers
yeah what you mean okay okay i
understand but i just
would you agree dante i've just found
that a lot of men are like confused at
times about like
what is like wanted and what is unwanted
would you say that's true or false
uh you know i try to take a neutral
point on it because i see both sides you
know i see guys that are nervous i get
messages from these guys like how do i
talk to girls i'm so nervous
and i literally don't know what to do i
freak out so i see that side of it which
you know there there might be an excuse
like a guy comes up he doesn't know what
to say and he says the wrong thing but i
think there are also a lot of guys on
this earth
that feel like they have power and feel
like they can say whatever they want to
and it doesn't really matter what the
ramifications are and to those guys
i'm giving that to you right now because
you make it a lot harder for the other
guys that actually give a [ __ ]
to have a good conversation without
being objectified from a woman
or to say something respectful or what
they view is respectful and then they
could judge for it
so i think there's two sides of it and i
think honestly most guys are inherently
good
i think this goes back to the start of
this conversation is
why did all men are trash or men are
trash even start
and i think for a lot of guys now they
were cheated on at an early age right or
a woman completely shattered their heart
and so from that and this goes both ways
it's a you know it's a bounce off effect
they go all right well any girl that i'm
with now i'm going to treat them like
the girl that cheated on me so they're
going to cheat on that girl
or they're going to be disrespectful or
they're going to say every woman is
going to go and cheat on me so why would
i give all of me to that
i'm going to close off my emotions so i
think a lot of guys coming from a place
of hurt
and i think that goes to all men are
trash when really the first person that
hurt them was a woman
so i'm not saying oh my god no um i
asked someone the other day like what if
the players you know do you feel like
they've
always been players or they were made
oh no
oh shoot i think we lost pro again no
i i do have actually like some like
insight about
just from the biological standpoint of
everything that happens because
it isn't just from woman but it's our
attachments
and and i know like dating coaches talk
a lot about attachment styles but
you know how our parents raised us our
caregivers like gave us
you know love is how we perceive our
relationships and how we want to treat
our partners right
oh i was just yeah oh um pearl can you
hear us
yeah sorry my internet um i was just i
was
just telling dante dante from a
biological standpoint
you know the reason why men and women
act like players is because of their
attacking styles
and how that we are given love in kara's
babies because that is our perception of
how we should go about in relationships
and the form
the love that we give and the love that
we receive and so people
go about life thinking that it's okay to
treat someone like that
and and it's not just from childbirth
but also like
our relationships how we those personal
experiences
form our approach and our view on life
and how we should treat people and so
it does parents have a very large
responsibility in making sure that their
children
are you know not being a little [ __ ]
and
by giving them love and respect 100 yeah
100 percent
no what were you going to say before you
cut off oh my gosh i forgot what were we
talking about
i was just talking about the fact that
you know a lot of men feel that they
need to treat women the way they do
which is toxic now because they've been
cheated on first oh i just was
hurt i asked a guy um actually it was my
brother i think
i asked him if all the players that he
know that she done their girlfriends
were they like have they always been
that way or were they made and he told
me nine out of ten were made
because a girl died that would happen
and that's the thing
cheating rates like girls always want to
blame men and say that
28 women cheat at 25 so it's virtually
the same
i've been cheated on twice how many
times i've cheated
zero zero
thank you and i don't say that for
sympathy or anything but i'm just saying
to throw that out there that there's
this notion that only men cheat is
[ __ ]
i honestly think women cheat more than
men do i think men are caught a lot more
well and women a lot of times they don't
i don't think women hold other women
accountable
like there would be girls in the locker
room like bra almost bragging about it
and nobody was
saying anything so that's so messed up
like that guy loves you why are you
doing that you know
like doing that to him but girls girls
will say things a lot like
i don't know men might say this too
behind closed doors but i've heard girls
say things like oh it was just in the
moment and i
felt i felt so suffocated in this
relationship or something like that but
i'm like
okay then leave and then hook up with
someone else
and i would say i would say a lot of
times men and women cheat for different
reasons
i think a lot of the time when men cheat
it's because they feel like
they don't know who they are they need
to find themselves in someone else or
they don't feel loved enough
whereas for women they might have
someone that's on military leave and
they don't feel like they have
anyone to talk to they don't feel like
they have um
someone to spell out their emotions but
they don't feel like they have a
connection with anybody
so for them they just want to feel loved
by somebody for a quick moment and that
leads them to go cheat or they don't
feel like that person they're in a
relationship right now
loves them like even if they're seeing
each other day to day so like let me go
find someone who can actually give that
to me short term
because i feel like i'm stuck in this
marriage with four children and i get
beat every single night
let me go find someone that can actually
do it for me and give me the love
yeah which is a terrible situation and
you should leave that situation but it
does happen
so i was reading a paper last night
talking about like
general anxiety and relationship desire
and satisfaction
and they noted that it's you're
absolutely right dante
men and women actually have different
reasons
for why they feel dissatisfied in
romantic relationships and it's because
for men it's when they feel like they
have to
over provide especially if they're
highly anxious about a relationship
they have to over provide overcompensate
and it gets to a point where it becomes
so emotionally
exhausted exhausted that they have to
withdraw
and they end up seeking other means of
like trying to figure out like oh like i
want to like
find another woman and that's that's
actually from a scientific perspective
and then for women ow i just hit my knee
um for a woman it's i think it's
the romantic encounters and it depends
on your attachment style which is
interesting but it's the romantic
how how loved you feel and then
women end up just withdrawing all
together and they end up cheating
because they they want to find another
means of love which is absolutely true
and
um but less less high anxiety
men that tend to withdraw in
relationships are
i think they oh yeah they
they seek out casual flings because they
don't view sex as something that's
sexually gratifying which is
yeah do you did you see the part where
they said that
um rich men tend to cheat more do you
find that to be true or false
i find that personally as a man and i
know a lot of you know
people in that position that are
successful when i was younger i used to
work at a country club i saw that
firsthand the guys that were making you
know well over 300 400 000
for cheating on their wife all the time
and
i think the notion behind the idea and
kevin samuel said this you know if you
expect to get a man that makes over 200
000
a year which divorce rate drops i think
he said 24
instead of 50. he says that the reason
that happens is because these
people come up with rules in their
relationship and a lot of times that
means that the man when he's out on the
road and he's not with his woman he can
cheat
um or he can have his fun if you will i
think that is a really
dumb mindset to be completely honest
with you and i think if you're a woman
that's trying to get into a position
where you can be provided for
but not fully love your partner because
you know that he's gonna go cheat or
he's gonna run off and do something else
i think that's dumb i think it's an
excuse for men to say you know i need to
get my dick wet and i can't control
myself
so i need i need you to tell me that i
can go do that so that i feel better as
a person
that's ridiculous um but i do think men
that have more money
well they can find women easy easily who
who'll do
that because if if a girl like there's a
million girls that would be like
he can cheat that's fine if he's paying
for everything i get to live in this big
house
go like there's a lot of girls that
would say yes and would you have
i think a lot of guys if they have the
option to do that would prefer it but
most guys
can't which i think is terrible but it
happens not the majority you know what
i'm saying not the majority of them but
but there's a good chunk of men that if
they had the option to have a wife
and sleep with whoever they want on the
road like we're gonna be like
okay yeah it happens all the time in
athletics too you know i was a college
basketball player i'm sure you know
pearl 2 how a lot of athletes operate
it's like they know they have the
opportunity that they're going to take
it you know
any time we're on the road my teammates
the first thing that they would look at
is what are the schools around here
saying go sleep with a girl
not all of them but some of them um and
they seek that opportunity out
and that goes back to people don't know
who they are so they're trying to find
themselves in someone else or they don't
feel loved so they go to sex immediately
and long term a lot of those people
realize and i know this firsthand
because i was with these people
is they've had sex with over 100 girls
right and they get to a point where they
feel like there's absolutely no
gratification from it and they feel
empty and they go i just want one person
and i think it takes a certain i think
it takes a certain amount of time and i
actually told them from the beginning i
said you know you're not going to find
value in that
eventually they got to that point and i
think it takes everyone a point of
maturity
to say i don't want to do that i want to
be with one person that i love
because at the end of the day when
you're 70 years old you're not going to
look back and go man i had a lot of
great sex
yeah it's cool but you're going to want
someone that's going to sit by you
bedside and tell you how much i love you
i can support you i can be there with
you and you can raise a family together
and if you don't want that don't be in a
[ __ ] relationship
damn mic drop that was great actually
thank you um i think that's actually a
great way to end the podcast unless you
have anything to add ari
oh no i think dante ended on a really
great note
yeah that was great um
well thank you guys for chiming in i
think i've recorded this but i don't
think i'm live because we've had zero
viewers the whole time
so i'll probably i'll probably upload
this uh
because i know it automatically records
so i'm gonna upload it to youtube do you
guys have a channel
i do yes i am oh sorry will you just
message it to me
both of you your channels if you have
them i can tag you in the description
yeah absolutely i'm starting to put out
content again because my job is
requiring that so
yeah all i'm i'm going to start making a
youtube channel and
also i will be in touch with you guys
and reach out if we want to like bring
you guys on the platform because
they're wanting to bring influencers on
and i really think this could be a great
way to even do like the flutter
flutter high pass but we'll like rebrand
it and all that but
yeah yeah sounds good thanks for coming
on
yeah thank you bro yeah thank you for
having me
yeah um have a good one i'm gonna end
the broadcast now
okay bye bye guys